[Applause]
[Music]
kuwait is along with guitar the only
country in the Arabians and infinite
where elections are held yes you heard
that right
many of you might move this country
because of their oil reserves their
wealth all the facts that they were
invaded by saddam hussein in the 90s but
Kuwaiti is much more than that it is one
of the most tolerant nation in the
Islamic world women can vote they can
run for office and they even have a
female MP but not only that for decades
the Kuwaiti royal family has been
America's best friend in the Gulf this
is why when they were invaded in 1990
Uncle Sam didn't hesitate for a moment
and sent in their troops immediately
this will not stand this will not stand
this aggression against Kuwait and now
you might wonder why are we talking
today about Kuwait well this is the only
Arab country alongside Amman that hasn't
joined the diplomatic block of Qatar
[Music]
Saudi Arabia Bahrain Egypt and the
United Arab Emirates broke off relations
with Qatar in the worst diplomatic
crisis to hit the Gulf Arab states in
decades the three Gulf countries and
Egypt accused Qatar of supporting
terrorism and destabilizing the region
and now the big question is why is to
wage not on this list of nations who had
cut ties with Qatar what kind of
interest does this country have in this
diplomatic crisis how does that mystical
system work
well today we are going to answer these
questions but before we do let's get to
know a bit more about this particular
part of the planet is who in the Persian
Gulf the first country we need to know
about in the Arabian Peninsula is Saudi
Arabia Saudi Arabia is the biggest
country in the region both in terms of
population and territory but it is not
the only country here
here we have the United Arab Emirates
which Devine and Abu Dhabi are a part of
this country has its own government its
own laws and its own currency and is
absolutely independent from the salaries
the same goes for Qatar which has its
own foreign policy and holds better
public relations with enemies of the
Saudis like the Islamic Republic of Iran
and I'm everything that all of these
countries have one important thing in
common the fact that they are all
incredibly oil-rich right well actually
that's pretty wrong here we have the
Republic of Yemen a country that is
extremely poor now of course all of
these countries have a common history
common traditions as well as religion
but make no mistake each of them have
their own peculiarities for example the
United Arab Emirates was the first
country who realized oil is not forever
and therefore they decided to diversify
their economy so they crude represents
just three percent of the total economy
of divine Kuwait is also a totally
different animal yes they have a lot of
GeV so-called Emir but he is controlled
by a constitution and the Parliament
but the hulls on for just a second
because this doesn't mean they are a 100
percent democratic country in fact their
system it's way more complicated than
that so well let's have a look at it now
[Music]
how does semi democracy work in kuwait
kuwait is known as a semi democracy
unlike Saudi Arabia Kuwait have a
freedom of religion this is why you can
even find a Catholic Church in the
middle of Kuwait City things like that
your job on not mandatory and even the
laws regarding alcohol they're fairly
liberal in comparison with their natives
of course it's still forbidden to buy
and sell alcohol but it is legal to
drink in private
nonetheless the main peculiarities about
Kuwait are their elections all the adult
natural-born citizens have the right to
vote their Parliament every four years
this includes women in these elections
political parties are forbidden
doesn't mean candidates have no ideology
at all they can also campaign freely and
have debates needless to say the
political debate here is totally
different compared to that in the UK for
the u.s. here the political spectrum is
not only a right wing left wing kind of
thing of course some candidates are
highly conservative and others are more
liberal and open to Western culture but
this is not the only thing that divides
Kuwaiti society there is also this
never-ending fight between Sonny Muslims
and Shia Muslims this is because as I
said before there is freedom of religion
and that means the creed of the
candidate is an important disease tax
plan but not only that there is another
big divide between the so called urban
voters and the so called
tribal ones just think about it for a
moment this is a country with a long
nomadic tradition with half of the
population still living in tribes and
these trying to hold their own primaries
to choose their own candidate
[Music]
well said elections are used to choose a
national assembly with the power to make
laws and even put a veto on the policies
taken by the executive branch at 911
wondering how do they treat the Prime
Minister are they voted for by MPs as
they do the European countries or do
they hold presidential elections like
they do in the USA well it's actually
nothing like Indra so as I said Kuwait
is a semi democracy this means that the
head of state is the Emir and he Tunes
the Prime Minister and his cabinet so
maybe this sounds like those European
absolute monarchies that you studied
about his history there well it's not
really exactly like that
in fact in Arab monarchies the position
of Emir is not inherited this is why in
Saudi Arabia they have big internal
battles to choose their leaders and as I
explained in a previous video royal
families in this part of the world can
have thousands of members
[Music]
so in the case of create the members of
the royal family the so-called al
Sabbagh house can vote for the Emir but
right after the National Assembly has to
vote on whether they can accept this
decision or not this whole one now for
just a second because the just engaging
system wasn't complicated enough
here is another extra fact the
Constitution allows the Emir to dissolve
the Parliament many time you want sound
well that's something he does pretty
often here of Kuwait dissolves
Parliament the move announced on state
media after an emergency government
meeting sets the stage for early
elections and believe me parliamentary
debates into eight are far from being
quiet emergency meetings are a common
thing and sometimes it's really hard to
get any kind of consensus for some
analysts this is one of the reasons that
explain this
a cruder holic economy we all know it
oil rich countries have so much money
they can spend as if there was no
tomorrow
most natural born 280 citizens work as
civil servants for the government they
pay no income tax their energy bills are
subsidized and their salary is well
they're ludicrously high the people who
work on oil rigs
well stead of foreigners but this is not
only a reality for to ace it happens all
over the region
black gold has allowed all of these
countries to enjoy this way of life
[Music]
but the big question is well what
happens now as you probably know the
market price for crude oil has fallen in
recent years of course these oil
monarchies are still making profits but
not enough to keep that system going and
this is why it today all of these
countries ask fiscal deficits this means
their spending is way higher than their
income
[Music]
pay any attention through the chart here
even the USA a country which is really
worried about his deficit is doing
better than these country and now you
might wonder what does this figure
actually mean well this means that if
the two AG's don't want to go bankrupt
in just a few years they'd better find
some alternative incomes and not rely
entirely on oil nonetheless despite you
eight having the most modern and
democratic political system they have
the highest dependence on crude oil even
Saudi Arabia regressive as they are is
better prepared for a planet in the
price of oil and this is a surprise for
everybody because during the 1970s to
eight was the rock star of the region
now this title goes to Dubai despite it
being an absolute monarchy and this is
less than any Arab is wondering whether
democracy is compatible with economic
reform we have stagnated frustrating the
people of a country once seen as a
Middle East Trailblazer let's say that
you want to start a logistics company in
Dubai you just need to buy some land and
build the facilities right well thank
you wait this is almost impossible the
government owns 90 percent of the
territory on the other hand bureaucracy
has reached insane levels according to
the World Bank it's easier to start a
business in countries like Ukraine or El
Salvador and than it is in Kuwait
and all of this is despite the fact that
q8 has a lower corporate tax rate within
Luxembourg added to this are the sky
high salaries and civil workers which
rise year after year and you can
probably imagine it that no one is going
to become an entrepreneur and leave
behind the comfort and safety of a
government job even the Kuwaitis
enclosure and they're learning outside
because they cannot do business degree
they try to do the short-term good in
the short term but now all of a sudden
the Qatari crisis has offered create a
chance to emerge as a regional leader
their royal house has good relationships
with all the countries involved
including the United States Saudi Arabia
and Qatar but their political system is
the most open and democratic in the
region in other words they have the best
chance of becoming a mediator in this
crisis and they're well aware
wait to the mirror to travel to Saudi
for Qatar talks so now the question
becomes do you think two ways can take
back its role as a regional leader can
this crisis help them to showcase their
country for foreign investment well let
us know what you think in the comment
section below we're waiting to hear from
you
[Music]
meanwhile things are far from quiet in
Saudi Arabia their royal house is having
an internal war to determine who in
going to be the successor of the prince
click here if you would like to know
more about that story and of course do
not forget to visit our friends at the
we consider media podcast they provided
the voice you heard on this video so
that is not mine
and don't forget we publish brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so please be subscribe to this channel
and you won't miss any of those videos
and finally if you like this video
please do give it a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you in the next video
and if you'd like to hear more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider the podcast that covers
politics but we don't do the thinking
for you available on your favorite
podcast see you there
[Music]